but I want to switch gear a little bit
in the talking about another place where
intelligence will come up daddy is
really intelligent they're digital
assistants katana I want to talk about
katana I'm sure by now you have heard a
lot of the intelligent assistance you
know popping up from know many many
companies you definitely have a question
that in the so what's so unique about
the Microsoft Cortana I tell you two
things about the Microsoft Cortana
that's really unique number one
Cortana is really designed for you to go
across your work life your work and life
and as you can imagine that the lines
between work and life are really blurry
just think about that you know your
email accounts that they use at a home
and you use their to work so this why we
actually design katana to become the
best digital assistant to help you to
get things done you know whether you're
the home at a worker on the go
and for example katana will help you to
find the emails and they remind you your
commitments you may or may not already
forgotten and the recommended meeting
times on shared accounts so this is why
that we actually have now the support to
really have helped you to work across
different the email systems so we
actually now can work you know added it
now Gmail support for calendar and the
email so that katana can help you get
across multiple email systems so I'm
very happy to announce that you know we
actually you know have this ability
today you know in katana you will see a
demo very soon so the second thing very
unique about the katana I want to share
with you is that it's not really about
our own katana devices only so we really
want to bring katana to as many devices
as possible and the way for example
launched this Harman Kardon speaker
recently was a beautiful in a voice
quality and Aldus no digital assistant
quality and the user experience and we
also announced this partnership you know
katana and the Alexa you know with
Amazon because we actually believed
it's important that we offer in a very
unique user experience especially across
walk in the life on different devices
but that's not all we also want the
katana to appear in as many applications
as possible you know what is Microsoft's
own windows and the office and others
and all enjoy and iOS applications in
other platforms so this why you know I'm
so excited to announce in a two new
mobile launcher or Android platform our
own Microsoft launcher and cheetah
mobile and our public you know we
actually have one of those top in the
productivity launcher in Android Google
Play Store and the cheetah Mobile's
launcher will be available immediate
with our katana embedded and the
Microsoft launcher we have katana
capability in a couple of months so this
integrations with katana is really we do
that to help we know more people across
multiple platforms it's really coming
back to my earlier point that is you
know you think about that the lines
between walking alive getting blurred
why did you need a system where did you
need a system so this is really in our
commitment to help people to get things
down even faster so one thing I want to
remind everyone is that you know as we
design those digital assistants like a
katana it's really about the
conversational AI it's really not just a
bother you have one question then you
get an answer then you get out of there
it's really encourage you to getting
into the dialogue so I want to invite
Christina to come up to show you some of
those interesting now katana demos
Christina so first and foremost Cortana
is a fantastic workplace productivity
assistant it can help with things that
normally take a lot of time and a lot of
steps
one example is finding time with my very
busy VP Geordi hey Cortana set up a
meeting called FY 18 goals with Geordi
rebus looks like you and Georgie are
both free
at 9:30 a.m. on Monday January 8th when
would you like to meet 9:30 a.m. on
January 8 okay
I've scheduled FY teen goals with you
and Jordi at 9:30 a.m. on Monday January
8th is that right
yes got it January I told you he was
busy before today I would have wasted a
lot of time going back and forth trying
to figure out when we were both free but
now with Cortana because it understands
my calendar and Jordi's calendar it can
suggest the time that's best for both of
us beyond a pure workplace productivity
assistant we all know as Harry said that
the line between work and home
they're blurring more and more each day
the real value in Cortana is in its
ability to move across devices and
across the different aspects of our
lives it's difficult to schedule a work
trip if you don't know what's on your
personal calendar and we all know that
sometimes the most urgent email that you
receive during a work day is from a
family member or from a friend
Cortana summarizes across your different
email accounts hey Cortana what new
emails do I have you've got six new
emails in the last hour one from Adam
Kirk marked important three from Emma
Williams and two from Jordi rebus which
Center do you want to hear more about
Adam place Adam Kirk email view about
Cirque Dreams holidays marked important
what a Harriet yes please
it says don't forget to buy tickets for
your parents visit what do you think
about a Friday XO me what should I do
with this reply or nothing nothing
alright we're all really busy people but
because Cortana blends my work and
personal life by reaching across my
different email accounts I can take care
of things as they come up of course I
could set a reminder and take care of
this later but there is no time like the
present problem is I don't actually
remember when my parents are coming to
town hey Cortana find mom and dad on my
calendar you have mom and dad visiting
at Seattle from Wednesday December 20th
to Wednesday December 27th okay because
Cortana is about helping you wherever
you are
it supports integration across calendars
with office 365 Outlook and now even
Gmail hey Cortana help me find tickets
to Cirque Dreams holidays in Seattle on
December 22nd I have three skills that
can help you Ticketmaster gig seeker and
stub hub which do you want to use
Ticketmaster please okay opening
Ticketmaster I found Cirque Dreams
holidays in Seattle on December 22nd at
7:30 p.m. tickets are $40 to $80 do you
want to pick your seats or buy the best
seats available best seats available
please okay how many seats do you need
four please okay I found four seats
Rohde seats 6 to 9 sound good yes
okay I have four seats for Cirque Dreams
holidays at the Paramount Theater in
Seattle on Friday December 22nd at 7:30
p.m. the total comes out to 394 dollars
say confirmed to purchase confirm okay
you're all set
would you like me to add this to your
calendar yes please also invite Adam
okay
I've sent this event to Adam Kirk and
added it to your calendar thank you for
letting me get that taken care of now
let me walk you through some of the cool
things that just happened here instead
of me needing to know which specific
skill to ask for Cortana used skills
suggestion to connect me to the best
place to buy tickets and then connected
me to that third party skill and because
of my I have my credit card information
with Ticket Master my purchase process
was a breeze Cortana
then used a new feature called skill
training which understands my overall
intent to help me find the next most
relevant skill in this case it was
adding an event to my calendar how great
was that using my voice
Cortana was able to help me be super
productive in both work and at home all
of this done hands-free this calendar
feature is available now the next
generation of our Cortana skills kit is
also available today and then email
features that demo today or will be
available next month but of course
Cortana can help you in more places than
just this great speaker here's a quick
look in all of the place some of the
places that Cortana can help you be more
productive and get things done across
windows edge Skype and the new mobile
launchers
hey Cortana play my dance mix
[Music]
[Applause]
I booked your workout for 6:00 p.m.
tonight can I get you a ride
[Music]
hey Cortana what's next it's really
amazing to see you know how katana has
evolved into really powerful in the
digital assistance